rare moment d'harmonie entre les ces
chefs de partis fédéraux
il arrive sur scène conscients que leur
performance ce soir pourrait marquer un
point tournant de la campagne
il aura fallu à peine cinq minutes pour
que l'un d'eux jette les gants à la
défense des intérêts canadiens devient
le prétexte d'une première attaque à
l'endroit du chef libéral
vous vous cachez constamment derrière un
masque ironise à gauchir monsieur trop
fade
vous êtes un hypocrite un imposteur qui
ne mérite pas de diriger ce pays
les échanges sont vigoureux le temps est
sisyphe
maxime bernier souvent pris à partie en
france chef libéral l'occasion de
répliquer à son rival conservateur
votre rôle dit-il et de tir tout ce
qu'elle touche irritant privé shirt
exprès les propos de maxime bernier sur
l'immigration l'impôt le rôle des
provinces vont réagir
2on des stages au globo liste des
semaines ge money to buy si tu as
douanes sigad canso il n'aura fallu que
quelques minutes mais lorsque le chef du
npd et chose au lac tchad un avion de
0,3 point pour me confirmer que vous
n'avez pas votre place ici et dans une
mêlée où les échanges sont parfois
difficile à suivre
le chef du bloc québécois utilisent de
nouveaux snc lavalin pour se démarquer
accusant un douchez ou de perpétuer le
nom québec corrompu la question
d'avortement s'inviter dans la
discussion
le chef conservateur répète qu'il est
pro vie et métiers qu'il n'a pas
l'intention de rouvrir ce débat
le premier ministre ontarienne d'oxford
et d'évoquer à 3
courtoisie d'un justin trudeau désireux
de lier les deux chefs conservateur
si vous êtes si intéressé par l'ontario
rétorque à gauche il il y à un poste
vacant
ces libéraux provinciaux l'environnement
avait permis à justin trudeau de se
démarquer lors du premier débat devient
aujourd'hui le catalyseur des attaques à
son endroit
et alors que les chefs libéral et
conservateur s'attaque sans ménagement
jobit signe rappelle aux électeurs
qu'ils ont d'autres choix et après avoir
habilement esquivé la question de la loi
21 durant le débat le chef du npd a été
talonné par les journalistes ray c'est
d'offrir une position claire il est
demeuré évasif questions légales et ça
c'est une question de hypothétique mais
ce que je peux dire c'est légalement il
faut comme premier argument regarder
tous les cas ce devient devant la cour
suprême
de quoi alimenter le prochain et dernier
débat en français jeudi
ici daniel thibault radio-canada à
montréal